rankin republican on the house budget
committee
and he's looking for a conservative
fiscal fix at least somebody is
now welcome jason and i'm reading about
you and some of your colleagues
and you're actually talking about
bringing back budget caps
and i presume or if not i will encourage
you
to include the penalty of sequestration
if those caps are violated
so congrats for the thought now tell us
what's going on
actually you know larry it's great to be
with you
if we don't do something about the
excessive spending and put some kind of
statutory requirements of budgetary caps
and you have to have a penalty with that
whether it's sequestration or whatever
can be agreed upon
we have to do it you're looking at just
where
just the president's budget that has
came out you know 69 trillion dollars
worth of proposed spending
over the next 10 years that that would
lead to
deficits averaging 1.3 trillion dollars
a year
this year having the deficit over 3
trillion we got to do something
as you can see and as you've been
talking about we're in a crisis right
now
so okay let's just um back out some of
this
as i tried to explain um and i had this
great conversation with art laffer about
this
uh this afternoon you know the federal
spending is bad but
by itself it doesn't necessarily cause
inflation because those fiscal
multipliers
they don't do a thing they don't boost
the economy they don't really boost
aggregate demand
we learned that during the obama years
but as i said jason
it's the regulatory underbelly of all
that spending
that clogs the wheels of commerce and
cuts back
on the you know output of goods and
services right you follow
and then you've got the same money
supply chasing fewer goods and services
now i think my pal
mick mulvaney uh was on the network
earlier today or yesterday saying
something similar
that's the problem spending leads to
regulations
regulations lead to more
more inflation it's like backdoor supply
side inflation
that's why i want you to fight like hell
to get done
some reforms on spending
larry like what you said spending leads
to regulation
you all had it right in the trump white
house where you eliminated 22
regulations for every new one created
that's what helped grow the economy
whenever you
dangle out the federal dollar what that
creates is
is the the incentive to try to get more
command and control over the lives and
livelihoods of
families small businesses and farmers
and that's where the regulation will
come
they will say how you can spend it what
you can do with it we saw that in the
1.9 trillion dollar
biden bailout is what i called it some
people called it a coveted package which
really wasn't coveted
it had all the guidelines the
requirements of how
how that money could be spent whether it
was states or